we do have a verdict in the trial of
celebrity attorney michael avenatti who
has been found guilty on two federal
charges for wire fraud and aggravated
identity theft for stealing 300 thousand
dollars from his former client stormy
daniels alexis mcadams has the breaking
details for us right now she's live
alexis hi martha that's right this
happened just moments ago here so as you
mentioned michael avenatti has been
found guilty on both of those counts of
one wire fraud and two aggravated
identity theft that means he faces more
than 20 years now behind bars if the
jury was able to find him which they did
guilty on both of those counts now let's
get to what we know so far about
everything that unfolded in court this
went on for quite a few days here inside
of that federal court in manhattan and
there was a lot of things that were
happening there this morning though we
talked to michael avenatti as he walked
back into that federal courthouse in
manhattan saying that he was optimistic
that trial martha lasting about 10 days
with 15 hours of deliberations after the
prosecution called nearly a dozen
witnesses including stormy daniels now
the adult film star told the court that
avenatti lied to her every day for five
months claiming he cheated her out of
nearly three hundred thousand dollars in
advance money from her book deal
prosecutors say avenatti used daniel's
signature to send a fraudulent letter to
the publisher asking the company to put
that money in a bank account that he
controlled so then the court detailing
how avenatti actually used that money on
personal expenses like hotels meals and
even a monthly payment for his ferrari
so stormy daniels very upset about all
of these developments while she was
inside of that courtroom here in
manhattan avenatti representing himself
after he fired his public defenders on
day true 2 rather of the trial said that
he did this all because he had the good
faith belief that he was owed the money
and thought it was not wrong to take it
from stormy daniels throughout
deliberations those 12 jurors told the
judge they were actually struggling at
several points with the charge of wire
fraud sending out three questions about
the case and on thursday asked to see
the full testimony again from stormy
daniels so they could take a closer look
at also avenatti's defense here which
was as he mentioned he took that money
that 300 000 that he used to pay off his
car and his employees in la for his law
firm because he took it in good faith so
back in 2018 as we've talked about
daniels and avenatti became well known
as they appeared on tv together to talk
about her alleged affair with former
president donald trump daniels actually
hired avenatti to get her out of a
non-disclosure agreement that nda came
from trump's lawyer michael cohen at the
time who reportedly paid stormy daniels
about 130 thousand dollars in hush money
to stop her from speaking about her
alleged relationship with donald trump
before the election so once again just
wrapping that up avenatti now facing
more than 20 years behind bars after he
was convicted here in federal court
manhattan and martha this is not the
only case that avenatti is dealing with
he also has to serve a two and a half
year prison sentence already for his
conviction after he reportedly tried to
extort nike for 25 million dollars so he
has that going on and then also he has
another case out of california where
he's accused of stealing millions of
dollars from clients there's still a lot
more that needs to be done but it was
interesting hearing throughout this
trial here in federal court manhattan
martha that michael avenatti said the
whole time he was a hundred percent
innocent but the jury thought
differently
indeed the jury did think differently
and he is in a lot of hot water alexis
mcadams thank you very much i just want
to bring in for a couple minutes here
attorney brian claypool who has been
watching this with us so he faces on the
wire
charge alone
as much as 20 years in prison brian
what's your reaction to this verdict
hey martha great to be with you i'm not
surprised at all i mean i think i think
the evidence was pretty clear that he he
sent a letter
to stormy daniels publisher pretending
to be her and said hey send that first
advance into
michael i have an audience client trust
account i mean clearly he was intending
to defraud her and quite honestly i'm
surprised that the jury took so long
because a lawyer with integrity martha
their best defense here would have been
hey i have an engagement letter right
with my client that sets forth how much
money i'm supposed to get for helping
you get a book deal where's that
engagement letter there was no
engagement letter that would have been
his best defense so his human behavior
alone i think convinced this jury that
he intended to defraud her and he never
had any reasonable belief that that
money was his yeah um we're going to be
with admiral kirby in just just a second
i just have you know one more question
for you he chose to defend himself do
you think that was a mistake given how
this played out
um i think it's always a mistake to have
a defendant represent themselves i i
think you need a neutral voice uh to to
advocate for you because jurors are
they're gonna have trouble believing you
martha because you're you're advocating
for yourself that that that's human
nature you're going to say that i'm i'm
innocent so i i think that that was a
big mistake and by the way he's in a ton
of hot water out here in california too
for allegedly stealing millions of
dollars from clients and also for bank
fraud and and bank wire bank fraud and
bankruptcy fraud
well it wasn't long ago he was a star of
uh other cable news networks and some
were even suggesting that he should run
for president i think he suggested that
at one point um brian claypool the story
of michael avenatti a major fall from
grace for him as he's convicted today on
wire fraud and identity aggravated
identity theft mike uh thank you very
much brian good to have you jumping in
here for us on the breaking news we
appreciate it
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else